We now turn
to the subject of war,
specifically the Hashtag War.
Now...
tonight...
we're wondering what it would be
like if Senator Sanders' finger
was on the button, especially
one that does something
other than alert
his flight attendant.
Uh, what would Mr. Trump do
as head of state,
besides negging Angela Merkel?
Well, gentlemen, now is your
opportunity to go head-to-head,
mano a mano. Tell the voters
what the world would look like--
this is your final chance
to get their approval--
if you were sitting in the Oval
Office, with tonight's hashtag,
#IfIWerePresident.
Uh, examples might be
"our national parks would become
national golf courses" or, um,
"the White House
would get a chairlift."
Either one, either way.
Um, we're gonna go back
and forth on this one.
Let's start with you,
Senator Sanders.
Okay. If I were president,
"Hail to the Chief" would be
played by the band Phish,
and it would take 25 minutes
every time I walk into a room.
All right, points.
Mr. Trump.
If I were president,
we would have
the first lady-daughter
of the United States.
I'm disgusted. Points.
Senator Sanders.
If I were president,
I would put
the rich Wall Street bankers
in the same prison
that Magneto goes in,
but they would not be let out
for any sequels.
All right.
Points to Senator Sanders.
Mr. Trump.
If I become president,
I am gonna hunt down Rosie
O'Donnell like Osama bin Laden.
Points.
Senator Sanders.
If I were president,
I would institute
a national Netflix account
with one password
so we are no longer burdening
our seniors
for their Netflix passwords.
Points to Senator Sanders.
You're applauding that,
but do you know what that...
you'd end up watching
if everyone were
-on the same account?
-They don't even understand.
They don't even understand.
It would be Bones all day long.